salut francis veber heureux de vous
avoir
or le dîner de cons d'après votre
fameuse pièce dont qui sort demain avec
jacques villeret thierry lhermitte
daniel prévost francis huster alors le
produit avec ford a vendu absolument le
producteur c'est alain poiré ça on
savait qu'il aimait beaucoup d'avoir
tout votre travail vous coude et dans
les années 70 ensuite il avait acheté
les droits cinématographiques à la
lecture de la pièce mais la musique
vladimir cosma alors comment mais je
connais pas j'ai rien contre monsieur
costa mais comme en 1998 peut-on encore
demandé des musiques de films vladimir
cosma quand on a l'habitude
si je peux l'expliquer c'est par un goût
musical dans la mesure où il sait que
moi j'ai pas beaucoup de goûts en
matière de musique c'est à dire que je
suis dialoguiste et quand on met de la
musique sur mon dialogue ça c'est un
corps étranger mais c'est vrai qu'il m'a
fait la musique du grand blond avec une
chaussure noire c'est vrai qu'il a fait
la musique de la chèvre oui il a fait
logique de tous mes films alors bien sûr
ça monsieur claqué l'âge maintenant
parce que moi je vois son nom depuis six
ans 8 ans sans nom il doit y avoir il
doit avoir l'admira la cinquantaine je
crois avant à peine oui oui parce que
commencer je ne confonds avec joseph
kosma l'auteur des feuilles mortes en
fait joseph kosma est mort depuis 30 ans
le maire fait ça doit être ça parce que
c'est possible je sais que ce mât de
père en fils alors le film moi je les
vues donc je peux dire ce que j'en pense
je me suis marré je trouve d'abord qu'au
début j'ai pas vu la pièce un pour dire
franchement
au début quand j'ai vu arriver se snobe
de l'ermite je me suis dit ouh là là ils
vont se moquer des imbéciles vont se
moquer des pauvres et où ça va être
terrible donc j'étais assez énervé quand
j'ai vu qu'on voyait pas le dîner
pendant tout le film chevauchement
comptant bien entendu et je trouve la
fin extrêmement émouvante bon riz
beaucoup et la fin c'est très bien ça ça
formidable
je vous avais déjà pas mal de
compliments sur le sujet mois par est
devenu tout ça me fait plaisir et en
plus
non j'ai trouvé si vous voulez qu à la
fin moi j'avais une petite larme à
l'oeil quand il ya la dernière scène
entre pignon donc alors on va regarder
un extrait qui ont continué la
discussion magnéto je viens de vous le
dire juste leblanc
le blanc c'est son nom et c'est juste
son prénom mais champignons votre prénom
à vous c'est françois c'est juste et
bien lui c'est pareil c'est juste bon on
a assez perdu de temps comme ça ma femme
a signé le roman de son nom de jeune
fille christine me guirec
ah bon elle est bretonne je vous en prie
rester concentré excusez moi vous
n'oubliez pas enfin de conversation vous
lui demandez où vous pouvez joindre
christine le guernec ça soit je voudrais
sur haut parleur
je prend l'accent belge est non alors
alors oui c'est vraiment drôle alors dis
dans ce film il a coûté 80 2 millions de
francs alors ils sont où les 82 millions
de francs parce que bon vous vous en
vous en prenez une partie j'imagine la
plus grosse partie et c'est moi qui
j'espère pour vous donc la tour eiffel
derrière c'est pas la vraie tour eiffel
non mais c'est plus cher
ah oui bien sûr c'est une vrai que vous
avez fait construire une aide à 4 tonnes
et demie c'est tissandier le décorateur
hugues tissandier qui a voulu et les
rues raison donnée à l'appartement
quelque chose de entre guillemets
gigantesque pour enlever la claustro du
théâtre ouvrière
donc j'ai effectivement le luxe d'avoir
une tour eiffel merveilleuse et c'est
fantastique parce que moi on a
l'impression de ses appartements du
champ de mars live la tour eiffel qu'on
pourrait toucher du balcon de 82
millions donc sérieusement le temps le
temps d'accord le temps c'est très cher
au cinéma le temps et comme je voulais
donner un rythme au film pour le dé
théâtralisée on a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé au niveau des prises
mais tara est de faire quelquefois 30
prises avec les acteurs on en parlera
après de façon vous êtes un maniaque
pour ça que ça marche alors la pièce
faisait 2h20 vous avez fait un film
d'une heure vingt donc c'est bien ce que
vous disiez mais c'est un vrai film que
je dis il n'y a pas de super bon c'est
pas du théâtre filmé les relais des gros
plans qui rendent sa beaucoup plus
spectaculaire vais rajouter des choses
comme l'accident
oui et puis c'est la première que je
suis mon scop ce qui est bizarre parce
qu'avant j'ai filmé par an le jaguar qui
est oui à des paysages amazonien
merveilleux mais j'étais 1,85 et là
justement parce que le scope c'est le
format idéal du cinéma j'ai fait du
scope pour la première fois dans le
problème en films plus intimistes et de
voir le visage de villeray sur un écran
de 24 j'ai découvert que c'était des
paysages extradé vers les visas
un gros plan en scop est un acteur c'est
aussi intéressant sinon plus que les
chutes du niagara vladmir leur talent de
très près alors c'est pas facile
d'adapter parce que vous aviez fait
d'adaptation vous allez beaucoup
d'adaptations ceci on commence à parler
tout ce que vous avez fait en mêlant
minuit mais vous allez vers adaptation
de la cage aux folles pour le pôle
cinéma et vous vous disiez vous même
d'ailleurs que le film était moins drôle
que la pièce c'est difficile non acer
que dans le cas de la cage aux folles
c'était difficile déjà parce qu'ils ont
changé l'acteur oui ils ont pris tonia
dit qu'ils étaient italiens et qui a
joué en italien en face de ce héros en
français il avait signé le contrat pour
jouer en français et tonia dit quand il
a vu que ce héros était tellement bon
elhadi jouer en italien bon il va il a
trouvé la mort ce qui fait que ça à des
rythmes et le film et puis en plus la
pièce était une pièce d'acteurs la cage
aux folles ce qui fait qu'ils aient des
traditions tous les soirs et la pièce
pouvait avoir une demi heure de plus
certains soirs voyait donc le film qui
était obligée de canaliser de
contraindre tout ça n'était à mon avis
moins drôle que la pièce vaut bien
quelques complicités entre poiret
serrault losc a eu mais en revanche si
vous voulez j'ai fait l'adaptation de ma
propre pièce l'emmerdeur journée draaf
joséphine caisse a fait le contrat et
c'est lui le maire de l'emmerdeur et là
je trouve que le film est meilleur que
la pièce est de la même manière le dîner
de cons c'est mon adaptation sur ma
propre glace et ma propre musique parce
que c'est moi qui ai mis en scène c'est
m ont dit qu il a mise en scène au
théâtre voyait donc j'ai retrouvé la
distance cinéma je suis beaucoup plus à
scénariste qu'un auteur dramatique mais
toute façon vous dites aussi que les
pièces peut faire de très bons films et
une pièce où on a on a en commun d'aimer
beaucoup spécial dernière de 1,2 benech
qui s'attaque aux fans paige par billy
wilder et qui est une pièce au départ et
qui est devenu un film formidable
construction alors vous faites une
tournée en ce moment effectivement un
peu promotionnelle en province et il
paraît qu'il ya un type qui a demandé
est ce que vous serez pensée a tiré une
pièce de votre film c'était alors la
l'éclat de rire dans la salle et villers
bitat il lui a dit qu'est ce que vous
faites pour dîner mais alors il paraît
que spielberg a demandé là une cassette
donc doté de faire un remake de sa non
c'est pas ça s'est pas passé comme ça
spielberg a vu le film au ranch à
pacific palisades là près de los angeles
et il veut faire le remake seniors qui
sont en tractation maintenant avec
gaumont
oui bon il réussir à s'arranger au pas
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
spielberg veut faire le film comme quoi
quand vous envoyez la pièce à new york
personne en veut et quand vous faites le
film superbe est intéressé en le casting
est un spécialiste en tandem ou un de
vos films c'est toujours un tandem à
l'arrivée depardieu évidemment avec
pierre richard pour la trilogie la
chèvre fugitif et compère brel et
ventura dans l'emmerdeur
vous êtes un spécialiste en film
d'hommes ou départ ils sont pas mis à
prix deviennent amis ainsi qu'à votre
truc ça oui en tout cas c'est ce que
j'avais puis c'est drôle parce que les
références que j'ai dans le cinéma sont
faits les films que j'aime sont les
buddy stories des histoires d'amitié
je pensais la traverse est pareil avec
gabin et bourvil
je pensais à be nice cowboy oui pensez à
larnack butch cassidy si oui c'est vrai
oui oui à tout comme ça il est tout un
tout un genre du film il ya de l air
dans la comédie le cordiaux et la grande
vadrouille de funès bourvil c'est aussi
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas pris brasseur
il trouve yeux et écoutez c'est
cruellement disent que vous venez de
dire en fait et il faut que l'acteur le
cinéma est plus réaliste que le terrain
on peut imaginer effectivement sarah
bernard jouan l'aiglon à 60 ans ouais
mais là un homme de la génération de
brasseurs qui était épatant au théâtre
un qui joue au dîner de cons à la
soixantaine
ouais vous y croyez pas beaucoup il
faudra les deux par dieu qui était
pressenti était d'accord puis un moment
ça s'est pas fait non parce qu'il était
vraiment vraiment vraiment fatigué il
avait fait énormément cinéma il n'en
pouvait plus de nîmes et l'ermite
lhermitte le fait très bien dans votre
carrière j'ai commencé par faire des
études de médecine ensuite
rtl vous avez écrit des nouvelles vous
avez écrit évidemment beaucoup
d'adaptation et de dialogue pour le
cinéma on peut pas tous les citer
le magnifique une histoire formidable
une idée de vous le magnifique oui bien
sûr une magnifique mais vous pensez que
gros câlin peut massacrer à la réal non
bah oui parce que j'ai retiré mon nom
oui oui je n'ai pas mis votre nom je
vais pas signer le générique peut-être
que j'étais un peu violent à l'époque
parce que le film tient à peu près le
coût si vous voulez mais de branca qui a
un style de cinéma bouffonne ans et les
acteurs jouent comique
oui c'était pas du tout ma musique vous
ce que vous dites aux acteurs toujours c
c'est à moi d'être comique toi tu joues
ton truc et puis c'est moi qui m'occupe
que ça soit comique c'est lorsque vous
dites au sujet de des films des frères
du caire la deux
leslie nielsen qui n'est pas en fait qui
n'est pas quelqu'un de très comique
sérieux jeu sincère et juste sincère et
c'est ça votre truc
le jaguar ce bon ça a bien marché ça
fait 2 millions et demi d'entrées enfin
pour un film qui a coûté 115 millions
c'est pas non plus le pactole comment ça
se fait là d'un seul coup on a dit
webber nous fait de la métaphysique et
tout cas ce qui s'est passé on attendait
passe à la gta meunier effectivement
chez moi le sujet m'avait touché mais je
me suis pas rendu compte que c'était un
peu enfantin si vous voulez le sujet je
suis pas rendu compte que un sujet de
maïs peut passer pour un sujet bête
j'aime beaucoup à voir mais on m'a
reproché de faire de la métaphysique
d'almada un peu et je peux pas lutter
contre le jugement là je pense qu'il ya
éventuellement ce problème et puis le
tandem n'était pas fonctionné pas aussi
bien que d'habitude entrerez nouer et
bruel aussi c'est pas ici de juger un de
ses enfants c'est pour ça que oui moi
j'adorais le savoir parce qu'en plus
c'est le tourner ça a été formidable
c'est bien mais oui puis 7e baugé dire
les paysages ça c'est venezuela tout ça
alors aux ulis avait fait deux films
donc le remake de fugitifs avec nick
nolte ecafé effectivement 45 millions de
dollars
quand même pas mal et welcome to
bouchaud alors là vous n'avez pas fait
le scénario est une catastrophe
en fait pourquoi je partirais unis parce
que la critique était méchante avec vous
en france non non non non je suis parti
parce que j'avais fait trois films à
plus de 1000 d'un million d'emplois sur
paris oui j'avais l'impression d'avoir
way à découvrir autre chose c'est là
qu'on m'a proposé d'y signer m'a posé
des consultants sur scénario c'est sûr
que c'est très flatteur vous rencontrez
400 berg michael eisner et où il vous
dit de venir là bas vous ai fait deux
films en ces temps on peut prédire que
il vous est fait vous travaillez vos
amis américains et vous dites on devient
pas américain à 53 1 550 ans à l'époque
c'est vrai un peu douloureuse pour vous
non non parce que j'y suis toujours
je vais faire un film la bassée dire
mais c'est vrai que c'est deux fois plus
de travail
dire que ici je suis chez moi oui et
c'est plus facile mais là bas on dit à
des migraines à l'homme qui a tout perdu
sauf son accent là bas et qu'il faut
effectivement que je m'habitue et je
bats d'après il ya les exécutifs zaba
c'est terrible mon dieu vous dites comme
un torero qui s'est fait encorner un peu
quand même un gîte en corner c'est plus
poli pied des trucs qui passent pas
présente les sentiments vous dites
l'achat puis dans lequel de vos cibles
de petite fille tombe amoureux du
personnage au départ le fugitif
enfin ils comprennent pas
pourquoi la petite fille tombe amoureuse
de toi est rationnel n'ya pas d'anti
héros alors que nous ça fait notre joie
est de toujours avoir une rédemption à
la fin c'est des trucs on n'a pas la
même
psychologie c'est vrai il que pour
réussir à hollywood les seuls qu'on
réussisse et ceux qui avaient fui le
nazisme ya ça parce qu'ils aient brûlé
leur vaisseau cerveau vous saviez qu'en
france on vous attendait donc c'est vrai
pas mal ma malchance c'est de ne pas
avoir hitler ici mais ça va venir
vous êtes obligés de vivre aux états
unis j'allais réussir pour de bon cette
fois je file tout de suite alors on
disait que sur le plateau est une sorte
de réincarnation de clouzot vous êtes un
tyran intégral elle vous fait faire du
jogging alors j'ai lu ça vous faisiez
faire du jogging à 2 par dieu à pierre
richard vous en dis avec eux remarqué
mais pour leur faire perdre des kilos
c'est terrible ce surtout à depardieu
parce que ouais une époque où il avait
tendance à huy à avoir plus de kilos
qu'il en fallait en particulier dans
sous le soleil de satan lui et la
débâche 1 avec l'ascétisme du personnage
et 130 kg sa peau l'acteur qui l'est
pour faire passer ça alors effectivement
qu'on me disais tout à l'heure donc vous
c'est vous le sait vous le boss sur un
plateau et vous reprenez cette phrase de
billy wilder
j'ai mis ces trois ans à écrire cette
phrase et a peu de chances que tu
trouves venu en trois secondes c'est une
bonne phrase ça c'est un truc que je
vais ressortir quand je vais parler au
patron des patrons de chaînes de télé
alors les meilleures comédies vous dites
sont basées sur des sujets dramatiques
c'est à dire toujours un regard décalé
sur quelque chose de dramatique cirque
en fait quelqu'un qui se prend les pieds
dans le tapis
ce soit drôle mais si son fils est
suspendu au balcon c'est beaucoup plus
fort beaucoup plus fort et si les
présidents des etats-unis s'est encore
plus fort ouais ouais il faut que ce
soit et décalées comme vous le dites
ouais
et puis des concepts artificielle aussi
faisait pas peur par exemple vous dit
certains l'aiment chaud ces deux types
qui s'habille en file pour jouer dans un
orchestre et il jouait c'est c'est
effectivement au début un truc
complètement vous partez toujours de
dinde un concept d'un postulat qui n'a
pas l'air d'être artificielle non c'est
pas grave si vous le demandez petit à
petit réel oui le gros travail c'est ça
en fait c'est de deuil du réalisme un
truc qui au départ peut être un peu
absurde quoi vous êtes fort enfin je
serve à nancy si vous êtes c'est un
boulot quoi mais alors vous travaillez
beaucoup énormément vous écrivez si l'on
tout petit comme ça au scénar et si vous
dites jamais été très doué pour la vie
et si j'avais plus aimer la vie
j'aurais moins écrit bien sûr pourtant
vous aimez luc si pareil que quand vous
arrivez dans un hôtel voulait la
meilleure suite que ça n'a rien à voir
vous pouvez très bien être très heureux
dans une chambre de bonne
malheureux dans une très belle suite oui
je dis pas que suis très malheureux mais
quand je dis que j'ai pas doué pour la
vie ça va pas dire que je n'aime pas la
vie mais ça veut dire que je suis plus à
mon aise quand je suis réfugié dans ce
que j'écris que quand je dois me cogner
au monde c'est pour ça que j'ai fait en
30 ans 25 films et 4 pièces
oui c'est que j'ai pas arrêté j'étais en
face d'un mur j'ai créé en face d'un mur
et je repartais avec quand même en face
d'un mur blanc pour ses sa campagne et
perrin du nombre de tours et pignons
opinion aussi il ya toujours un pignon
vous préparer quoi alors je fais une
comédie j'ai créé une comédie en
amérique en ce moment pour la tournée en
amérique en principe bon ouais ouais
à vous dégoûter non je ne lâche pas vous
vous êtes toute une génération daniel
filipacchi était un peu comme vous sert
des deux gens pour qui l'amérique
représente beaucoup de choses et qui
finalement voulait réussir aux états
unis trois générations d'après
finalement un mois j'ai dix ans - que
vous quoi pour nous c'était moi
important d'aller réussir aux états unis
fait vraiment dans une génération qui
veut marquer là bas c'est vrai tout
simplement on a en a eu cette génération
peut-être moi sûrement l'agression que
on arrive aux championnats d'europe le
jovial du monde se passe là bas
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas parce qu'on
peut très bien faire un championnat du
monde dans son propre pays c'est à dire
qu'ils ont fait et moi j'ai une espèce
de fantasme et je continue à la voir
mais ça non masure merci beaucoup merci
bebela michel déon bonsoir bonsoir
heureux de vous voir donc vous publiez
donc je le montre à la caméra comme on
fait la télé madame road chez albin
michel
en fait un moteur célèbre académicien
bien sûr auteurs célèbres fait partie
des quatre hussards avec blondin imier
laurent enfin je pense que dans cette
liste on oublie michel maure fraigneau
kléber et bien sûr enfin bon c'était
comme ça dans la petit opuscule de
bernard frank qui s'appelait sarah
grenier alors vous dit toujours que
c'est bien les us et enfin c'est pas
bien obligatoire pour vous mais ça
permet de faire un seul chapitre sur
quatre écrivains dans les histoires de
littérature et vous savez quand on vous
colle une étiquette c'est très difficile
de la douane est après les critiques ont
pas beaucoup de temps à laquelle vous
mettre dans un tiroir et puis après j'ai
créé pour la vie mais j'ai appris un
autre truc pareil à yannick avait
inventé un autre une classification
c'était les cols blancs dit
alors ça je savais pas du tout vous
faites partie de l'école blondy nist web
alors un petit peu tout le monde s'amuse
avec les mots choisis en littérature
plaisir voilà c'est le plaisir
alors après la montée du soir ce que je
faisais tout à l'heure quand vous étiez
en train de vous faire maquiller c'est à
dire bon c'est un peu votre testament on
avait l'impression c'est un peu votre
testament et vous vous dites d'ailleurs
à l'époque j'avais j'avais peur de la
mort
oui mais vous savez un autre toujours
cette peur la femme d'un certain âge et
j'ai voulu faire mon testament
alors que j'étais en très bonne sur la
terre parce que je n'étais pas sur le
jauge la mauvaise santé de pouvoir le
faire contre 8 depuis je m'amuse est un
peu comme quelqu'un qui aurait été opéré
du coeur et qui après vivre est une
espèce comme ça de vis supplémentaire
vous êtes aussi la folle du logis est
inguérissable apparemment quand on lit
madame rose c'est tout à fait vrai alors
je livre est publié chez albin michel
alors quand vous avez fait un truc que
tout le monde rêverait de faire enfin
toute personne qui souhaite écrire
rêverait de faire c'est parti un jour en
grèce puis en irlande et à l'époque vous
étiez pas sûr de vivre de votre
littérature et c'est vrai que jusqu au
poney sauvage c'est un peu compliqué
vous avez été soutenu par gallimard qui
vous donner le temps même je me souviens
qu'ils vous prêtez une chambre rue
sébastien-bottin m'aviez dit dans une
interview précédente dans bad minuit et
là vous passez chez albin michel
lorsqu'un pas très sympa mais je ne
passe pas j'ai donné un roman chez albin
michel et je verrai ensuite j'ai voulu
faire vous avec les petites infidélités
gervis d'or un peu glamour de votre
épouse c'est un petit écart a mis
d'accord alors madame rose bon j'ai pas
vu par raconter l'hymne enfants en gros
moi je parle du personnage s'appelle
gaston qui est fils de ministre qui
prend une année sabbatique pour se
chercher avant d'entrer dans le système
et qui va tous les après-midi à 5h
prendre le thé rue guynemer dans
l'appartement art déco de madame rose
face au luxembourg et elle lui fait son
éducation c'est ça en gros quoi le
faisait dans la maman les mains de la
profession et j'ai dit je suis un
consommateur de superflu alors il ya
trois personnages chez madame rose ait
said qui est son serviteur lui c'est
peter qui sont chauffeurs l'uci
c'est une demi-mondaine ses personnages
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai alors c'est
peut-être ça existe encore monter
l'écart ne s'appelle plus comme ça elle
est l'aînée une fille du peuple arrivé
dans le peuple
elle a eu trois mari dont elle s'est
bien débrouillé parce que ces débris de
rester riches et pas mal d'amis elle
aime bien la bagatelle
comment on pourrait la d aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on peut comment on pourrait
expliquer ce type de personnage est une
espèce qui a complètement disparue
nommément des noms été ruiné par les
mondaines des femmes du monde est entré
de la replace la rôle qu'ils jouent
exactement comme elle alors elle est le
vide la malle représente une profession
qui a vraiment pratiquement disparu et
en même temps c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup de classe qui a beaucoup
d'intelligence qui a beaucoup lui qui
après il ya tous les hommes avec lequel
elle a vécu auquel a été mariée elle
appris quelque chose c'est pas du diop
qui se fait ouvrir des périodes et des
bagues c'est quelqu'un qui apprécie pas
seulement son plan matériel a appris à
lire ce que tu es le théâtre qu'est le
sahel se policer elle est devenue
quelqu'un de très important et de demi
avec une intelligence rare d'ailleurs un
grand don de répartie mal marqué son
époque de 1910 à 1050 vous dit elle a
tout vu tout entendu tout provoquer
est-ce qu'on peut la comparer à kiki de
montparnasse dont on voit le portrait
par kisling sur la couverture
non je ne viens pas non le seul le
portrait lui va très bien parce qu'on
peut imaginer mais qu'elle était comme
ça quand elle était jeune mais qui
étaient tous mes jeux de l'aperçu de la
très vieille dame enfin surtout les
liquides mon papa j'ai aperçu elle était
vraiment traîné par l'alcool garrett le
naba et l s'envoyer en l'air si
facilement que la fin c'était devenu une
rude mais c'est pas son nom il ya une
différence de classe enfin cliqué tout
un modèle poser pour les teintes cas la
femme décline de tout le monde alors que
madame rose est quand même plus une
égérie qu'un
choisissez oui alors elle raconte elle
faburel convoi le confond les dates
c'est très amusant verre et vous ce qui
est quand même quand on lit ce bouquin
vous étiez parti donc je les dis en
grèce puis en irlande est toujours
beaucoup voyager au portugal etc et vous
ayez un peu laissé tomber paris après
avoir été un homme de la nuit après
avoir beaucoup être beaucoup sorti avoir
pas mal pas mal bu et là vous revenez
sur paris alors comment ça se fait vous
lâcher quand on y vit par les vagues
beaucoup plus aisément que quand on me
dit ça il faut pas toujours une certaine
distance je raconterai bien une histoire
d'amour quand elle est terminée oui on
ne raconte pas pas manquer c'est une
époque extraordinaire de libération des
moeurs de d'explosion des arts c'est cet
après guerre ce premier après guerre
n'ont pas vu là c'était là le sommet de
la vague
je crois que nous sommes au creux est
maintenant mort on a dit de cette époque
je sais pas où il a dit ça mais c'est
l'époque où les hommes sont devenus
militaires et les femmes sont devenues
folles c'est bien alors gaston apprend
il ya une phrase pourquoi on compte que
j'ai retenu c'est là il apprend que la
frivolité est un art l'amour une partie
de cache cache et que la dissimulation
est un jeu dont les femmes auxquels les
femmes sont souvent dans lequel les
femmes pardon sont souvent gagnante
alors à prix passe à la pratique va pas
raconter tout bouqaï lilia lucija odile
il ya céline et la fin rocambolesque à
ce que vous êtes bien marré 1 sur la fin
oui c'est vrai roman des révélations des
plus de théâtre etc
le style est très marrant parce qu'elles
emploient des mots évidemment le dit pas
lunettes elle dit bésicles son
mécanicien portant sur wii praticiens
médecins
elle appelle ça le petit parisien lors
c'est un grand professeur mois face aux
maux qu'elle a entendu alors michel déon
page 159 vous dites il ya un auteur dont
je me souviens pas le nom qui au
questionnaire de proust lorsqu'on lui
demandait quelle était sa qualité
préféré chez la femme répondait de
jolies jambes c'est vous tiens vous dire
c'est que j'ai retrouvé l'article en
vous répondiez ça un questionnaire de
primes suite à ces élégants de dire un
auteur dont je me souviens pas le nom
alors il y avait dans ce même papier
dans ce même questionnaire de proust de
là à l'époque donc il ya très longtemps
170 on vous demandait quel était votre
devise et vous disiez les carottes sont
cuites
apparemment vous n'avez pas changé
d'avis sur eux je trouve même qu'elles
sont la purée mais vous comparez
volontiers l'occident au titanic
c'est une image épargne mais enfonce
quoi vous avez un regret un peu du
voisin sentiment de nevermore par
rapport à toute cette époque d'avant
guerre en fait oui mais je voudrais pas
paraître la nostalgique de l'avant gage
qu'il ya des choses très intéressantes
aujourd'hui elles sont encore un
formulée elle te bouscule
il y en a trop je crois pas que notre
époque marquera bien la borne basse
câble est affecté de l de s'enfuir
d'interdits c'est une époque où le
politiquement et le ligament correct
bride l'imagination de beaucoup de gens
et en faire beaucoup
j'attends que une explosion il doit
quelque chose la classe et je ne sais
pas quoi est ce qu'on pouvait pas dire
un peu je sais pas qui a dit au moment
de la restauration en parlant de
l'ancien régime ceux qui n'ont pas connu
l'ancien régime ne peuvent pas savoir ce
qu'était la douceur de ville si stendhal
qui disent ah non là lugos chateaubriand
je me suis posé la question n'en sais
rien mais je pense que je serais plutôt
chateaubriand tous en voyant oui alors
vous partez en famille partait en guerre
n'exagérons rien mais enfin vous vous
élevez contre ce que vous appelez le ce
qu'on appelle le nouvel ordre moral
ces audits dès qu'on sort du lieu commun
on passe à la trappe quoi j'ai très
nettes mais enfin il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sortent du lieu comme age pas que
vous en êtes un des adeptes sortie ça
m'a coûté cher ami je suis pas passé à
la trappe me suis pas passé loin
dans une interview récente au figaro
littéraire vous disait que l'antiracisme
est devenue une nouvelle forme de
racisme pouvait expliquer cette phrase
écouter j'étais à paris quand j'ai vu
défilé sur le boulevard du montana celle
de jean-luc des pancartes la nouvelle n
non au racisme tout ça et j'ai regardé
leur paie non à la haine c'était ça la
première prend car j'ai regardé la tête
de celui qui portait là c'était la tête
la plus ému que j'ai jamais vue de ma
fille oui vous dites on peut même pas
remettre en cause l'histoire officielle
sinon ça se termine devant les tribunaux
c'est à dire ce que vous voulez dire que
vous êtes contre la loi gayssot
par exemple la loi gayssot j'en prenais
pas exactement les limites je crois
qu'elle n'a jamais été véritablement
appliqué sauf que non je crois que oui
c'est bien d'arrêter sa mère la jeune
actrice ce sera la même chose quand on
attaque les catholiques très simple nous
ça commence à vous avez vu il ya des
associations catholiques qui ont fait
interdire par exemple une campagne de
publicité qui reprenait la scène écoutez
dernièrement j'ai vu dans un journal
dans les kiosques que le pape avait deux
femmes
c'est ainsi que je sais que c'est une
blague gens s attirant mais il n'aurait
pas osé faire ça avec le grand imam ou
le grand rabbin sûrement pas vous avez
après chirac ou siens vous dites que
gribouille crevier règne à l'elysée
alors en fait gribouille parce que il a
dissous l'assemblée pour pas se mouiller
c'est ça pour pas perdre les élections
est tombé dans le bar vous dites que
c'est le champion du lieu commun a dû
parler pour rien dire ne vous êtes
d'accord avec les guignols là dessus ça
écoute je suis d'accord avec 50 millions
de français vous dites la grande
campagne de crétinisation est en route
et quand on aura crétiniser tout le
monde ce sera plus facile pour les
gouvernements de diriger les gouverner
pour élire de crétins plutôt de
préférence face à lui il a pas mal alors
dans votre jeunesse vous avez vous avez
vous dites j'ai combattu j'étais un
grand combattant des causes perdues
jusqu'à ce que vous partiez pour les
peaux les îles en fait en vous disant un
peu bon ben voilà il ya aucune raison de
se battre pour ce pays
vous avez été le cpl s'est pas vraiment
pas du tout pour des raisons politiques
je ne sais pas ce que j'aime la
littérature et j'ai été intéressé par la
littérature portugaise j'allais
m'installer au portugal pendant deux ans
ensuite j'avais très envie de connaître
la grèce parce que j'ai fait des études
gréco latine
et puis de l'irlande à cause des jo
c'est notre mère à tous ensuite j'étais
fasciné par le théâtre et entendait par
joe wright bail est pas tous ces poètes
et hollandais j'ai voulu aller voir
vivre dans les pays où il avait créé
vais pas tous vécu parce que beaucoup
ont été sortis et par l'irlande est
resté mon dernier ça parce que tu as
payé admirable qui prouve actuellement
passage par sa création pas c'est sa
force de créations extraordinaires par
le cinéma le roman la poésie le théâtre
que c'est probablement un des premiers
pays du monde alors au retour si on peut
dire que vous veniez souvent à paris
mais enfin là maintenant vous trouvez
que ça va toujours aussi mal qu'on en
fait c'est à dire que votre votre votre
exil volontaire finalement oui on la
veut rien à votre souffrance non non non
je ne fais plus tôt un peu sous la plume
savez je viens parce que je suis à
l'académie alors je dois quand même
bosser alors vous dites je suis ni de
droite ni de gauche me suis réfugié dans
l'utopie monarchie c'est à dire que dans
vos veines dans vos jeunes années
la monarchie est encore quelque chose de
possible on dit souvent si le comte de
paris était parti à londres en 40
peut-être que etc il va encore une
possibilité
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous une utopie
vous pensez vous pensez pas possible une
restauration monarchique en france je la
vois difficilement une à bonn faudrait
avoir véritablement un prétendant le
jeune vous êtes vous un spa
du bon côté il ya deux choses il faut le
dire sur lesquels vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec avec maurras dont vous
avez été prêté ce cadre d'actions de
l'aef
l'action française à lyon à l'époque
quoi il ya deux choses sur lesquelles
s'est pas d'accord avec moi c'est
l'antisémitisme et l'orléanisme puisque
laurent mauras pardon préféré le comte
de paris les orléans mais le fait qu'il
ait eu des républiques dans l'antiquité
on peut laisser présager qu'ils des
monarchies dans l'avenir non oui mais la
république finissent par attaquer mais
bon elle c'est ça qu'il faut éviter la
révolution de 89 a fini par une
dictature de 15 ans de napoléon ce qui
est pas mal pas mal je vous remercie
beaucoup il vous dévoile avec un quart
d'heure c'est c'est rapide je rappelle
le titre de votre livre donc madame rose
michel déon chez albin michel merci
beaucoup et à très bientôt
bonsoir ça la bienvenue en france
bienvenue chéri droite rive gauche alors
gadjo dilo donc ça a beaucoup de succès
ça marche très très bien le bouche à
oreille est excellent et en plus les
entrées sont bonnes alors c'est un film
soit liberté incarné par les par les
chicanes vous êtes avec romain duris qui
joue stéphane vous jouez sabina et si on
va raconter un peu l'histoire après mais
d'abord on va regarder un extrait pour
voir un petit peu le l'ambiance du film
[Musique]
en belgique d'un simple
voilà les en belgique tout seul mot rom
son mari un dense et il est resté la
palud
c'est également au complet mois stéphane
toi salut voila gadjo dilo donc de notre
ami gatlif tony gatlif avec romain duris
et puis renard n'a il est beau on a du
reste difficile pendant le tournage de
ne pas craquer j'ai eu un choc
je les connaissais pas ouais il est
vachement beau et il était pour moi à
user de quoi mais aussi les tsiganes de
la balle soit aussi bon ouais alors
c'était une concurrence des des mecs
beau partage c'est sur ce tournage tu
fais avant un show alors c'est
l'histoire donc de romain duris pas
stéphane qui va en roumanie pour
retrouver une chanteuse inconnue parce
qu'il est une cassette que son père
entendu pendant toute la fin de sa vie
qu'ils s'appellent norah lucas il essaye
de retrouver la chanteuse voilà et il
arrive dans un village il est reçu comme
les gitans sont reçues souvent dans les
autres pays c'est qu'on le traite de
voleurs de poules est content on se
demande si oui la minorité comme un
gitan ses visiteurs c'est ça c'est ça
l'histoire c'est très rigolo ils se font
engueuler parce que il nettoie sa maison
en fin de cycle des conneries voilà tout
les moeurs et les moeurs à l'envers et y
rencontre sabina que vous interprétez
alors vous vous êtes un peu différente
par rapport aux autres filles du village
expliquez-nous votre personnage alors on
dira qu'elle est une fille évolué alors
fille qui qui qui pète les plombs et qui
veut être indépendante mais elle est en
plus mais les considérer put vous là-bas
parce que est là et la bonhomie
abandonné son mari alors elle peut se
coucher avec qui elle veut elle peut
faire ce qu'elle veut elle peut se
maquiller elle est la seule un peu
maquillée toi mais pas beaucoup et elle
peut faire des conneries que les autres
font de parent parce que son mari était
en fait de l'habitat en belgique avec
son mari elle a abandonné son mari en
belgique elle est revenue en roumanie
c'est ça en fait oui marginal par
rapport aux autres ça c'est une un truc
qui tony gatlif je vois que il a il
avait besoin de beaucoup de films sur le
tigre pour le montrer c'est
secret aussi les tziganes dont une côte
et d'exclusion quoi pour les femmes qui
exagèrent et qui font n'importe quoi ce
à dire que tu peux être un ex être
exclue dans ta famille quoi mais ça
c'est une sacrée une de secret qui lui
le relève avec ce film parce que il a
beaucoup de choses dans les relations
amoureuses à des choix plus gros mots
avec des les rapports vraiment leur côté
un peu à bondir à voir si ce n'est celle
de ryanair entre le france et qui s'est
gentiment que j'ai 9 10 ans alors au
début donc votre personnage au début
sabina parle pas parle pas tellement au
début elle est plutôt muette elle
regarde tout ça et puis après évidemment
leurs relations une relation se noue
entre eux entre stéphane elle est alors
il ya une scène qui est quand même une
des scènes les plus torrides que j'ai
jamais vu au cinéma je dois dire que
c'est cuit c'est cette scène vous êtes
tous les deux et puis un souffle l'huile
à un souffle rauque et vous aussi
et à un moment vous le regarder avec des
yeux incroyable et vous lui dites
mangement à la chatte et j'avoue que
j'ai eu un début d'érection
non c'est vrai dans cet essai d'une très
très hot quoi et lui lui lui dimanche -
l'habite et regardez moi comme vous le
regardez quand vous lui dites ça nous ne
dit pas parce qu'on a la télévision près
pas le dire mais regardez-moi je vais
vraiment un drôle de un drôle de regard
vous dites des choses comme ça dans la
vie dont celle ci dans le film vous
croyez qu'on en dise alors je pense même
les mais j'écris aussi des poésies coiro
comme ça pour m'amuser même les polices
ils sont encensés grossier je crois que
jamais je vais pour le relais parce
qu'ils croient comme ça je pense qu'on
me sens je dise pour moi c'est je crois
que c'est important avant l'amour de
dire des mots comme ça ça chauffe le
partenaire ça chauffe aussi toi même
ça enlève beaucoup d inhibitions et des
des complexes des choses comme ça et
c'est con moi j'étais super content j'ai
j'allais à la plage de 10% dont moi et
alors c'est la même chose c'est qu'on
est revenu tout la journée pour balader
nu
dire qu'est ce que tu penses qu'il s'en
sort et ça ça et c'est une sorte
d'exorcisme qu'ils font les tsiganes
parce que pour eux prononcés tout ces
trucs là elles font que des crânes sont
petits dés que nous ont 50 font qu'elles
n'ont pas de complexe quand ils vont se
marier vers 12-13 ans et marche très
fort
ils sont choisis ensemble par botté par
fortune par choses comme ça part comme
s'appellent papa fortune argent de quoi
comme ça elles sont choisies et après un
verre 12/13 c'est marie et à 15 ans nous
ont déjà trois enfants et ils sont
mignons m'aide à 12,65 ils ont ils
savent tout comme le savent parce qu'il
parlait parlait d'une éducation un peu
libre conscience sexuelle exorciste si
au début d'ailleurs début du film quand
quand il marche sur la route stéphane et
pig iron croise pour la première fois
les filles dans la charrette
elle lui disent déjà des trucs comme ça
ouais parce que ça s'est passé quand
j'ai rencontré tony gatlif armani re lui
la faire un casting tranquille classique
avec une caméra par quelqu'un
et après il est venu en roumanie des
voix vraiment s'il a choisi bien deux
mois après cette cassette et il m'a
trouvé après cinq jours c'est d'éliminer
histoire tout le monde caché ton négatif
pour l'humour mettre une autre actrice
vient me chercher moi mais heureusement
c'est la résistance est à paris oui elle
est mort elle a disparu
je ne vais pas jouer zone et n'importe
quoi moi je les trouve quand même aimé
on a fait un casting de cette heure est
au bout de cette heure après j'avais dit
tout qu'est ce que je mangeais dans ma
vie et tout cas ce que j'ai appris plus
prévert global shakespeare racine et non
pas un roman normal dans une aile de
l'hôtel j' avais comment celui chargé
avec chanter ses parodies que je le
savais il a dit ça c'est super ça c'est
lui répondait fine c'est qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
alors une autre en avait deux radios
sont faits tous les couleurs d arc en
ciel comme ça vers veut son grade il m'a
dit mais tu t'es pas je crois que mes
dix montres la chaîne maintenant qu'ils
sont mises à brawn à je vous dis moi
j'ai il y avait visité la vous étiez la
roumaine la plus célèbre de france en
fait il y en avait une autre
vous m'avez adopté qui savent là on en
avait une autre mais malheureusement je
crois que la disparue maintenant que sap
et elvire popesco vous souvenez quand
même vous voyez qui c'est formidable
c'est une espèce que comme ça roumaine
quoi alors vous vous êtes roumaine donc
mais pas mais pas gitane un patch y
gagnent donc vous êtes roumaine votre
père était juif allemand ou juif
autrichien à votre mère était grecque
arménienne
quand vous étiez en roumanie avant de
tourner le film avec tony gatlif quel
était votre attitude par rapport aux
tziganes est ce que les roumains sont
quelle est l'attitude des roumains par
rapport à ces gens là roumanie c'est un
pays très original mais vraiment je vous
dise c'est à dire maintenant je peux
aimer les tsiganes et tout à l'heure six
mois moi je vois quelqu'un qui m'est
fait et je sais pas le connaître je me
regarde je sais pas je le dise la
grenade et d'exploser alors on marche
avec les instants et un mélo oui moi au
fond de moi j'adore le terrain parce que
j'en connais très très fort il aime
l'amour ils ont pour moi il représente
non une société qui est en train de
disparaître
la société de être ensemble quoi quand
on a beaucoup à apprendre c'est quand on
voit le film on envie enfin nous en tous
les cas français parisien on envie cette
espèce de libérer libérer d
possibilité de se mettre à danser comme
ça de chanter alors vous vos parents
étaient quand même d'une bonne famille
il était un peu bohème un peu baroque
mais d'une famille assez aisée quand
même et ils ont beaucoup souffert du
communisme en fait c'est à dire que en
1983 vous avez été envoyé en banlieue
vous ai quitté une belle maison que vous
aviez j'imagine abus car elle dit je
sais tout je sais donc vous êtes obligés
d'être parti en fait partie en banlieue
et voir votre grand mère vous dites que
votre grand mère et le chien sont
devenus fous oui alors moi je vais vous
dire c'est pourquoi je crois que je suis
très attaché de paris parce que cette
gaffe en france et des communistes et le
parti communiste ici ça existe toujours
en france moi j'ai un peu d'une sorte
d'allergie quand j'écoutais communiste
ils m'ont fait a assez de cauneille quoi
mais je sais pas possible comme ici le
sont d'autres façons moi tout seul chez
soi c'est ça c'est bien alors on avait
roumanie mon quartier
à bucarets c'était exactement comme
c'est le cinquième jeu c'est
arrondissement ouest comme ça un canton
comme ça c'était et là bas maintenant
ils sont des hlm et des routes sont
pourvus well soon des routes pendant
paranoïa comme sa grande île ont rasé
des vieilles maisons pour vous mettre ça
et alors quand tu viennes à paris c'est
le premier show qui tu l'as tu dis c'est
pas vrai ça c'est mon bucarest les quand
j'étais petit
qu'est ce qui se passe quoi c'est plus
comme ça tu t'es pour faire tuer ce coup
pour faire cette espèce de grandes
bâtisses l'est soit conscient son
château ah oui là les cas ces désirs des
églises orthodoxes magnifique
là bas c'était le quartier juif et moi
j'avais aussi un peu plus
en france des pêches parce que c'est ici
on a le temps mais malgré tout ah oui
vous dites que vous entendez les trois
syllabes du mot communiste vous cracher
par terre j'ai fait une allergie quoi
hein j'ai fait l'énergie
bah ouais donc c'est ce qu'on prend un
autre des ders vous avez été vous aviez
commencé un film à une époque et vous
avez été chassé pour la fille d'un
dignitaire communiste avait pris votre
place dans le soir c'était vraiment
magique et moi ma main pour mes enfants
quand j'étais déçu je crois qu'après
avec la musique je vais je veux donner
le bout et après après la leur au lavoir
révolution j'ai recommencé le théâtre
parce que je croyais d'anthony 89 je
vais recommencer attraperait la
révolution vous êtes devenu alors gatlif
dit que vous êtes la nina hagen roumaine
moi je veux dire je trouve beaucoup plus
joli que nina hagen côté armani j'étais
comparer beaucoup de temps avec
joséphine baker
ouais enfin vous êtes une sorte de renom
roumanières vous êtes célèbre en
roumanie
vous êtes une sorte de pasionaria de
land art grande quoi vous avez fait des
pas mal de groupes de rock et chanter
sur scène j'ai fait des films de
vampires aussi que des productions
américaines
ils vont tourner la balle et une de
vampires c'est moins cher oui c'est
clair c'est ça c'est une raison mais
c'est vrai que mon premier film c'est un
film de vampires jeu mais combattait
avec elle comme à tester mon professeur
qui après le maïs parce que j'avais et
repris par lui l'avait n'importe quoi et
c'est toujours comme ça si tu fais de
cinéma peut pas faire du théâtre de la
musique tu ne vas pas le droit de faire
du cinéma
et alors je sais pas comment je les fais
je les avais je faisais comme la
prophétie cinq choses alors c'est vrai
renac avant le casting avec tony gatlif
vous avez vu votre avenir dans du marc
de café c'est vrai ça vous avez vu dans
le marc de café un petit cochon qui
signifie l'argent est un lion première
chose vue les figures de tony gatlif
c'est comme ça que je les repérer et
c'était pas moi c'est ma copine tamarac
et la repérer dans le café quand tout le
monde le cacher il voulait pas me donner
ses coordonnées pour que je le rencontre
pour les castings
alors comme ça elle a fait porter le
metteur en scène qui tu vas apprendre
dans le film est alors c'était c'était
comme ça je fais un tour eiffel est-ce
que vous tamara vous savez lire dans le
marc de café non j'essaie aussi voir que
vous ne le ferez à leur goût
oui alors je vous avais une croix autour
du cou parce que vous avez fait une
tournée de toutes les églises alors
orthodoxes musulmans catholiques
vous avez choisi catholique parce que le
curé vous a dit dans la religion
catholique on peut aussi croire en soi
rend plus de dieu c'est pour ça ouais
ouais
et moi je crois en moi d'allemands
étoiles oui c'est le demande de dieu
j'en est remis à dieu maintenant
bonjour merci coûté j'étais ravie de
vous connaître en tous les cas je peut
encourager tout le monde d'aller voir le
film de tony gatlif c'est vraiment un
plaisir et à très bientôt je suis sûr ça
lui donne un bon soir bon ça alors on
fait petit petit cv en vitesse un jean
marie gourio hara kiri charlie hebdo
auteur des guignols brèves de comptoir
donc ses douzième depuis 12 ans et les
nuls et les nuls maternelle et les nuits
l'auteur des nuls aussi brèves de
comptoir ça va s'arrêter en l'an 2000
c'est vrai oui j'arrête en l'an 2000
dont il ya encore deux à 1999 oui c'est
terminé je n'écoute plus les records de
vie notre idée après pour non non je
dirais dans les bistrots et j'écouterais
rien ça va être un peu j arriverai pas
bon ok on était donc les brèves de
comptoir qui ont été adaptés au théâtre
par jean michel ribes
vous avez publié si un truc à vous et
publie un album avec villemin qui
s'appelle i claires égales a été retiré
de la vente sur 1,7 oui il ya eu 1
on a eu un procès et tout ça pourquoi ce
que les anciens nazis parce que vous
traitiez hitler de ss non oui non non
c'était donc c'était de l'humour sur les
camps de concentration ouais alors
évidemment c'était on aller très très
loin c'est un album de bd très pro ouais
mais ça a été assez mal compris et puis
ça y est on a préféré le retirer
alors là c'est votre cinquième revanche
je le montre à la caméra comme on fait
la télé voilà s'appelle chute
c'est chez julliard 1 alors l'histoire
est assez drôle c'est l'histoire d'un
type les paras qu'un type assez simple
de l'univers d'un milieu relativement
prolétaires et qui pour séduire une
bibliothécaire qui s'appelle mathilde
fait semblant dur délivrance et ça c'est
l'histoire il là il la voit dans un parc
elle est splendide
il la voit et puis voit qu'elle c'est
une jeune fille en train de lire donc on
a les moyens de séduire une jeune fille
c'est d'être aussi belle qu'elle est
donc il va essayer de la cdu en faisant
semblant de bouquiner voilà alors il a
une approche pascalienne sur ces mets
toi genou prix et tu croiras pas c'est
pareil ça il prend des livres il les
regarde il et il essaye de comprendre et
tourne autour et les relier cela oui les
feuillants côté animations les dix ans
le papier touche le papier les attend
quel bouquin il le reprend c'est un
objet sensuel c'est l'odeur du papier
l'odeur de l'odeur de la colle l'odeur
du savoir un lover du savoir et alors il
c'est un peu un roman dont le livre en
fête est le héros quoi c'est ça c'est ça
c'est tout tout tout se passe autour des
livres mais il ya aussi votre histoire
personnelle j'imagine enfin je sais pas
c'est celle d'un gamin des rues 10 ans
dans l'aube dans la mère décédée dont le
père est un peu bourru on dirait un peu
le père de julien sorel moi je milieux
populaires évidemment aucun il servait
plus à décorer les murs comme
l'encyclopédie narcy universalis on en
avait 21 21 en volume à la maison oui
c'est ça alors là il ya un mètre vingt
d'encyclopédie universitaire du sart et
les voisins et puis on en veut en parler
après c'est le gars là la mer dans le
bouquin la mère est morte en sauvant son
dans la mer à mimizan il ya une chose le
seynois y est c'est quelque chose elle
avait réussi une plume de mouettes
oui c'est ça elle était en train de
bouquiner les 1275 âmes de jim thompson
qui est un très beau polar est en train
de le lire
tout d'un coup elle arrête de lire et
prend une plume de mouettes qu'elle
glisse dans le roman policier est ferme
le roman policier le pot sur le sable
elle va se baigner
elle se noie le père est fou furieux les
fous de rage parce que le père dit c'est
le livre qui a tué ma femme voulait
d'ici la page il aurait continué à lire
elles seraient pas allés se baigner
serait pas morte il sera avec nous voilà
donc si l'allemand le père va arrêter de
lire dans sa vie même le journal et tout
bascule en veut aux livres d'avoir tué
sa femme est finalement eu une fois que
le fils va rencontrer cette bibliothèque
l'air va rencontrer mathilde ça va
remettre un peu les l'amour en route
dans la maison grâce au petit bouquin
qui vont venir
ouais et le père se remettra à la
lecture aussi parce qu'il va chercher le
père cette fameuse page 27
qui aurait pu sauver sa femme qu'elle
est la page 27 sublime de qualif sublime
que ma femme n'aurait pas abandonné et
donc quelle page 27 aurait sauvé mais
c'était avant c'est à vivre votre roman
est très étonnant alors ça commence
effectivement la maison avec un m
un de l'encyclopédie universelle du
savoir et ya le reader digest reader
digest et sélection on appelait cela
dans les clarines et dans les cabinets
il dit même avec tous nos qu'accablant
même avec ceux de noël on n'arrivera
jamais à finir non c'était pas pour lire
d'abord cd livres pour feuilleter
cabinet puis on les feuillette
c'est compliqué parce que il ya plein
d'auteurs inconnus comme c'est pas des
livres en entier c'est pas la peine de
les lire il ya déjà des sélections de ce
qui est très important c'est que tous
les livres s'aligne donc on a une
étagère dans les cabinets où il n'y a
pas un livre qui dépasse et ça c'est
déjà magique
alors il ya un rapport on disait très
sensuelle aux livres et ça commence dès
le début parce que quand ils voient
mathilde dans le parc de nérac en train
de lire ce sont le bouquin il dit
salengro sortez et mouiller le bout de
son doigt et les jeunes filles qui
pollinisent comme ça les coins des pages
c'est déjà très sexy sans qui dope c'est
alors qu'il n'ya pas les livres les
titres de livres dans votre monde son
temps entre guillemets je me demandais
pourquoi puis à un moment un truc
formidable c'est qu'elle ramasse le
savons ils sont au pressing
elle ramasse le savon de pontgibaud et
il ya juste la majuscule s majuscule
mais d'un seul coup le livre fait
vraiment partie du monde parce que je
ramasse le savant comme c'était du savon
voilà c'est ça c'est comme ça c'est un
objet voilà un objet serre que voilà un
bouquet le ventre de levante de paris
c'est un livre c'est un objet voilà les
livres ont une présence et la présence
physique des livres c'est ce qui oblige
à enlever cette espèce dia pas de
guillemets ya pas de différence voilà
guy malé les enlève le livre du monde
physique pour le mettre dans le groupe d
pour eux les bouquins c'est sans
guillemets c'est le monde le monde des
choses décès les affaires comme quand on
va à la plage ai dit tu as bien ranger
tes affaires les affaires c'est quoi
alors c'est la serviette pour essuyer
c'est le truc sur la tête pour pas
l'intérêt pour par l'association ouais
c'est la gourde bien fraîche et c'est le
livre c'est les affaires le livre étant
une affaire comme parler de l'hôpital
aussi on arrive avec des magazines et en
ressort avec des livres épais comme ça
selon la maladie est régisseur
formidable dans votre dans votre bouquin
il ya d'abord quand il découvre l'amour
évidemment et découvrit de pouvoir à
gond les yeux d'elsa en décollant ils
font l'amour faut dire avec la
bibliothèque dans une partie de la
bibliothèque avons réparé l'ellipse
voilà dans une salle derrière qui
s'appelle la source où ils réparent tous
les bons coups a assuré alors ils
découvrent en décollant le fait il ya un
moment aussi il est à poil et à son sexe
qui est dressée comme ça évidemment sur
cyrano oui oui il est en train de lire
à poil dans la cuisine elle est en train
de se laver les cheveux le matinée dans
la cuisine est dit [ __ ] elle adorerait
me voir nue en train de lire et donc il
en train de boue qui dément pas si pense
à elles et puis en train de vendée comme
un iphone comme mon sexe comme un roc
comme un pic comme un cap une péninsule
etc
il est devant son livre quand même et
comme il a du mal à 60 ans il ya
l'histoire du poil du cul sur les
rêveries du promeneur solitaire de
rousseau aussi c'est sympa ce qui laisse
des traces sur les livres quand ils font
l'amour et tout d'un coup il ya un poil
de cul comme ça qui change complètement
la phrase parce que je lui ai donc il ya
une dame ramène les produits du les
rêveries du promeneur solitaire en
disant regardez
effectivement on sent que le que le
l'esprit de rousseau n'est pas tout à
fait le même dans la phrase à cause
d'eux j'essaie 2,1 attendue des
mouvements il ya aussi une course de
lecture dans le pari non dans le train
paris nantes où lui enfin le narrateur
et puis un autre en outre frimeur ils
sont en train de faire une course
poursuite qui viennent plus vite à la
wii donc il fait semblant de lire et
tout temps qu'on fasse de lui à
quelqu'un qui est en train de lire le
même prix que lui c'est rare il va être
un peu il en a à peu près partout h à
15000 et page 15 le petit tour n'a pas
j'ai dit attention à mon pote
quand il tourne la page aussi loti
tourner ton étoile il se rend compte il
lui c'est pas possible il est comme moi
il fait semblant
effectivement à la fin ils arrivent à
nantes il a fait semblant de lire 340
pages de procès le poids ce qui est déjà
le père pour enfants alors combien
faut-il dire de liste pour être cultivée
ça c'est sa grande question un poil et
la culture quoi il s'agissait pas à
peut-être qu'ils ont fait aucun faux
1200 faut dix mille c'est pas et comme
il faut lire il faut dire comme un
tambour est intelligent et est-ce qu'on
sent le moment où on ne pouvait que si
on est con à 14 livres est ce qu'on est
cultivé au 15e
dans ce cas l'or dans l'es15 et puis on
arrête parce que si on les cultive au
15e le 16e et ce qu'il sert à rien alors
c'est un milieu aussi c'est un milieu
très très populaire on dit abîme pas les
yeux à lire ça mais moi je me suis à ma
grand-mère me disait toujours tu vas te
fatiguer le cerveau quand elle me voici
élira le musée toujours tu vas te
fatiguer le cerveau oui c'est des
espèces d'attitude un peu ça et puis tu
vas être bossu époux m épate épinards
selon tu te salue les socquettes et puis
avec le doigt quand on suit avec le
doigt oui si c'est la grand-mère un
regard de langlade y lit dans ta mère
fois les angles pour pas qu'ils pensent
des petites peaux et tous en forme alors
ce qui est très rigolo dans ces sites un
style quand même il ya des histoires
formé de ça un peu touffu le style si je
peux me permettre une
elle est très bienvenue non vous qui
faites des choses tellement accessible
en général c'est vrai que la laddh la
même histoire et peut-être peut-être
plus accessible via un style littéraire
il ya un emportement bien emportements
voilà même du personnel pour des
livreurs tout d'un coup il en veut il
envoie là on voit là il voit des
milliers de livres dont il ya un moment
il faut les raconter ces milliers de
lits mais l'emportent la confusion et et
sa façon d'approcher les bruits ses vues
du vue de son point de vue alors il ya
des brèves de comptoir dans le livre
évidemment on pouvait pas y échapper il
ya un type qui dit oh le dernier gagnant
du loto le [ __ ] 15 milliards ce
premier parce qu'il pense à 50 de ses
skis là il a un mal fou à se concentrer
sur les procédés aux étoiles est donc
évidemment il pense aux bus qui passent
un rip en somme égale au 15 alors quand
il y deux tauliers de skier des
noisetiers donc il prend de la crème de
noisettes en faisait des correspondances
qu'il a une sensation comme ça il dit
pour être beau avec 1 et 2 de qui parle
de noisetier c'est d'être bien dans une
crème de noisettes donc il fait des il a
eu un comportement extrêmement loin
wisser et littéraire très vite parce
qu'ils passent par la chaire des livres
mais aussi un moment patrons de bistrots
qui parle de comment s'écrivent les
langues alors gauche à droite droite et
à gauche de haut en bas de bas en haut
il ya un qui s'il se trouve un mec qui
dit le chinois j'ai peut-être parce
qu'ils s'en foutent c'est pareil s'il
sera discutée mais un livre qui arrivait
au comptoir d'un bistrot change
complètement le way la conversation il
le rapport qu'on a avec les potes autour
du livre alors la fête c'est donc le
brèves de comptoir qui vient de sortir
alors bon il y en a des formidables on
n'a pas le temps il y en a une c'est
l'archéologie le lit doit une fière
chandelle à l'egypte
oui pianote sur l'egypte l'egypte elle
est aussi bien au louvre que la barre
biya been juliette binoche allait quand
même plus binoche que juliette ou sur
mars parce qu'il ya un petit camion qui
roulait sur maçonnerie mais j'ai alors
ils veulent qu'on marche sur mars
on n'arrête pas de prendre la bagnole
paix sur la terre ouais bien un qui dit
aussi la lune
la lune c'est fini ah oui là l'insee
film a une c'est fini et la meilleure
console de jeu quand assez france les
habits bon c'est toujours aussi bien un
bravo parce que douze ans après un oui
moi je me suis marré je me suis marré
tout seul en le lisant
et c'est rare bon alors la première que
vous aviez noté maggetti siens quand on
s'était rencontrés dans paris dernière
sur cette même chaîne d'ailleurs la
première dédiée noter c'est à hara kiri
c'est un mec qui disent toujours l'ena
ou là vous en souvenez oui les nains
c'est comme les crevettes tarrach la
tête il reste le maître la bd ça sans ça
ils adorent est simple il y en a des
doutes qui disait souvent quand les mecs
il est un peu comme ça avec la bière la
maladie dont tu rêves que tu dors ouais
voilà c'était ses phrases et les sorties
sans arrêt parce qu'il savait qu'elles
étaient très efficaces et la dernière
que vous ayez noter vous et votre petit
carnet là non la dernière que j'ai le
thé non non j'ai pas de petits carnets
avec vous à vous bossez - déjà là je
suis un petit peu ça et pas autrement si
cétait s'ils avaient passé la geôle au
bistrot mois les engueuler quand vous
buvez pas beaucoup fait attention on
fait attention mais en même temps vous
dit que quand vous vous n'allez pas au
bistrot de la journée vous avez
l'impression d'avoir rien foutu quoi il
me manque que ouais ouais
oui oui il me manque une musique une
odeur il manque une présence il y manque
un même si elle même si la personne dans
le café si le seul il veut je me manque
rien les bons bistrots un saut aux
portes de paris
parce qu'il ya du passage ya de l'aller
retour fut laquelle est bon client alors
comment vous reconnaissez les bons
clients ceux auxquels il faut prêter
l'oreille aux coudes way a le coude un
peu le coude un peu usés sabrina c'est
des petits cristaux et sans répit russes
eux aussi qui devient pour cinq minutes
et puis voilà et puis pour la 5e rang
puis à la place parce qu'il ya des vrais
jouisseur iliad il ya des gens qui skie
à 40 pour la première fois dans un café
il se met exactement à l'emplacement
amis comme les chiens qui tourne qui se
cale dans le fauteuil exactement il
fallait se gagne donc le client il
viendrait qui vient juste aux petits
bouts on voit tout à l'emplacement
mettez les bottins banque ou le
distributeur de cacahuètes lui alors
l'a6 mais là tout seul
saint-prot de nous on était là pour un
quart d'heure et ça fait un quart
d'heure ça y est ça passe vite
ça passe on était bien on rigolait bien
donc je rappelle le titre du bouquin ces
chutes c'est jean marie gourio chez
julia cet excellent et si brève de
comptoir chez michel lafon donc ça c'est
toujours toujours très drôle merci
beaucoup
les corrections de nourrir
t2i nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu